on va dire un mot parce que l'europe
voilà ce que dit l'accord sauf erreur il
faut que je retrouve là pour être en
capacité d'appliquer notre programme
respecter le mandat que nous aurons
donné les françaises et les français il
nous faudra dépasser ses blocages les
blocages et être prêt à désobéir
certaines règles européennes en
particulier économiques budgétaires
comme le pacte de stabilité de
croissance de droit la concurrence les
orientations productiviste et néolibéral
de la politique agricole commune et
cetera n'en jetez plus dans le respect
de l'état de droit ils sont jamais ça
c'est l'europe à la carte non non rien
bayod écoutez je vais vous répondre mais
si vous terminez de lire la phrase prêt
dans le respect de l'état de droit sans
jamais sortir de l'europe de l'euro ni
agité la désagrégation de l'europe quel
est le fond du sujet bien je viens
vous est posée est-ce que ça c'est pas
l'europe elle c'est ce que je fais
madame c'est ce que je fais madame moi
j'ai écrit tout un livre qui s'appelle
désobéissons pour sauver l'europe parce
que je considère et nous considérons
notamment que le cadre austérité a
installé la limite à 3% nous empêcher de
mener des investissements dans la
transition écologique j'ai écrit ce
livre en 2018 2019 et je disais c'est 3%
nous empêche de développer les énergies
renouvelables de développer la
rénovation thermique nous l'aurions fait
ce sont des centaines de milliers de
ménages qui serait dans une situation
plus favorable aujourd'hui voilà ce que
nous avons raté à cause de ce carcan
l'austérité et le fait de privatiser les
services publics toutes ces règles elles
ont volé en éclats c'est la pandémie et
la france d'ailleurs jamais été
sanctionné pour avoir dépassé les règles
budgétaires et voilà ça c'est bien une
règle pour appliquer ce programme pour
appliquer ce programme il nous fera
effectivement si nous voulons construire
du logement social que c'est un
investissement rentable sacré l'emploi
était d'accord pour pendant la crise
sanitaire que effectivement tous les
pays des roches à l'arrêt il ya eu un
accord des 27 si tous les pays font
comme vous prévoyez de le faire c'est à
dire
désobéir est prêt d obéir à certaines
règles européennes que si chaque pays
fait sur l'annoncé poussant est-ce que
ça n'est pas faux pose la question
est-ce que ça n'est pas une europe à la
carte bien sûr que non bien sûr que non
le portugal l'a fait l'allemagne un
point oui sur un point où il ya toutes
ces règles j'ai dit le droit la
concurrence ces orientations une somme
non laquelle nous vous savez peut-être
que nous sommes nombreux
membres écologistes de gouvernements en
europe a souhaité non pas la sortie de
l'europe europe ecologie les verts je
pense qu'on peut pas faire plus clair
nous sommes écologistes nous sommes donc
considéré comme un des pays les plus
europhiles vous associer à un martin il
considérait comme un renfort excuses
est-ce que nous sommes prêts européens
oui est-ce que nous sommes satisfaits du
fonctionnement actuel de l'union
européenne non personnes dont l'une est
pas les politicards isoler la pauline
indica 27a de la politique agricole
commune nous avons voté contre non pas
parce que nous n'en voulons pas mais
parce que nous n'avons pas pu peser
suffisamment pour la réorienter
l'autriche qui a un gouvernement avec
une coalition écologistes à une pac
verte une politique agricole commune
verte c'est donc possible et donc il
s'agit de mener cette bataille au niveau
européen non pas pour en sortir mais
pour la ré orienter désormais en
allemagne vous avez une coalition dans
lequel c'est pas rien vous avez deux
super ministre analeena barbeuk ministre
des affaires étrangères robert à bec
ministre de l'économie il m'avait voilà
les verts allemands travailler avec le
luxembourg avec la finlande avec
l'irlande dans lesquelles il a fondé
gouvernement et que le jeu reste assez
fou en fait ce rapport à l'europe que ce
nouveau rapport à l'europe que vous avez
conclu avec la france a ajouté la france
insoumise elle dit on va déroger aux
règles c'est son argent
nous allons déroger aux règles sur un
certain nombre de points en attendant de
modifier les traités parce que
effectivement ils ont intégré la
nécessité de modifier les traités
continuons cette négociation pour
modifier les sinon ces discussions
passionnantes j'ai expliqué que et vous
l'avez dit ce cadre osterrieth r il n'a
jamais été respectée en vrai je crois
qu'il ya eu 160 5
infractions pour non-respect des 3%
c'est un parent de maastricht où les 60%
ça c'est l'endettement nous savons ça
tout ça a été mis entre parenthèses vous
l'avez dit du fait de la pandémie
la question est on à un moment
historique faut-il un retour au statu
quo et bien nous disons non au contraire
l'europe peut être un formidable outil
d'investissement dans la transition
écologique c'est ce retard que nous
n'avons pas fait un pacte d'ailleurs
écologique un green deal qui a été
conclu a été
écoutée si vous mettez le gaz dans les
énergies vertes on ne sort pas vous
comprenez bien qu'aujourd'hui on s'en
mord les doigts en tout cas j'espère à
la fin des années 90 je verrai à la fin
des années 90 et eu un tourment tournant
vous me dites que c'est l'europe moi je
peux pas l'expédier en 30 secondes gens
nous sommes
et donc je termine par vermine d'impôt à
la fin des années 90 il y avait une
majorité à l'époque avec 15
gouvernements en europe y avait une
majorité de gouvernements sociaux
démocrates ils ont raté le virage
c'était la proposition de la réduction
du temps de travail du salaire minimum
et des grands travaux 1 la rénovation
thermique notamment pour développer le
potentiel et améliorer la paix la
prospérité en europe ils ont fait les
critères de maastricht le traité
d'amsterdam c'est bien donc possible de
réorienter c'est une question de volonté
politique voilà ce que nous voulons
faire enfin modifier la coalition s'y
engage et j'appelle toutes les forces
pro-européennes à venir batailler avec
nous pour réorienter le cours de
l'europe merveilleux que nous avons
devant nous ne pas au contraire retour
au statu quo mais quelque part les
esprits ont bougé même à la banque
centrale on parle désormais délégation
de la dette vous rendez compte ce qui
était aux gens ce qu'ils étaient il ya
quelques jours aurait dit des choses que
l'on dit sauf que vous dit pas comment
j'en tire les conséquences il ya ceux
qui parlent et nous nous voulons agir
pour réorienter le cours de l'europe et
nous avons des minéraux pour ce faire en
allemagne en irlande au bénin manière
sur le fond de l'accord avec c'était
mauvais et brigitte jeux pour les
enfants et leurs parents pendant j'ai
bien compris
[Musique]